we are going to talk about our favorite
shooter this year just up front this is
not reflecting gamespot's like I don't
like our game of the year awards this is
just us to be talking about a favorite
shooter we did do like which shooters
for which upcoming shooters for you kind
of a key move back alone with that way
no like that's not it now I screwed up
yeah sorry for people listening rob just
like obscured a camera completely
different yeah so instead of doing like
what shooters for you between titanfall
battlefield call duty which all released
like you know it was battlefield Titan
Belgian golden I already said it right
the first time battlefield on phone call
duty yeah and then overwatch overwatch
was much longer guy but we want to talk
about our favorite shooters here um I'm
pretty sure all three of us have the
same one so I want to talk about them
all and kind of I'm gonna pick one that
might not be my favorite shooter this
year but uh uh mine I would I would have
liked we all would probably say
titanfall to right we are all big fans
of titanfall Tina's office that's one of
my favorite game this year it's weird
cuz when I was seeing things for
titanfall to normalize the thing you
guys talk about titanfall 2 I didn't
really care about it i didn't think i'd
like that much and i tried and sure this
is one feature no I mean I listened to
rob yeah you said that we sat down and
play this week we just played over
watching seinfeld to like their weekend
straight he's like do I wasn't
interested in until Rob told me if you
like cloak and shock and I was like Rob
is the one pulling you in this game
after I ranted about it for like two
weeks gave it a nine out of 10 it's a
good game it's really fun like and I
can't get enough of it like the
progression system they introduced with
it like we were talking about how I was
talking with Aaron today in the break
room he was saying like the progression
system they introduced like each new
like major upgrade you get whether it's
it's a pilot loadout or some like new
Titan ability that you can change up
just it makes the game fun in a new way
whether it's the phase shift with as a
pilot that you can just warp around with
or the the amp shield which I actually
been using a lot more recently which was
my favorite because it kind of demands
you be stationary as opposed to while
running whatnot but I don't know Rob
you've been ranting about this game
since we like we both went to the review
event for we've been playing a ton i
think you're the highest level out of
any of us i'm level like 30 regen yeah
regen ah we want to open with time fo
yeah sure
about it yeah yeah we'll try to keep it
just like I was playing a little time fo
one just like yesterday and like you're
seeing live where like they've changed
and they have changed everything in the
best manner one is the progression
system which gives you incentive to play
the game but what is continually
surprising me about titanfall is finding
new ways to play the game as well as
like being able to see different perks
and abilities having greater purposes
and also seeing people counter them like
there is such a balance to be said about
everything in that game everything you
can pick and choose has like a greater
purpose or counter I was telling Jake
the other day like ejecting the other
day and someone do this to me were now
as the game has been out and people are
getting much better at you know say
shooting and eject pilot that you've
just killed from Italian mine yeah you
think you got him you think he's a
sitting duck and then he throws a flame
fire star on your face and blinds you
and that happened me the other day I
went oh you just you're seeing people
learn different ways of handling
different outcome situations and that's
why they have a perk that allows you to
cloak and auto eject so you don't have
to never have to worry about dying in
your Titan right like there are just so
many ways that glorify like personality
and play style that I keep seeing and
finding and learning like I'm addicted
to North Star for instance the Titan and
the other day I I feel like I've
developed my loadout and I'm just like
exploiting that like cloak shotty with
like North Star like that's all I want
to do but then you start changing a
little bit of North Star and for
instance I started trying out one of the
perks specific to North Star is being
able to move around more when you are
doing kind of like Farah alt right or
the fly core or you know it's just like
a load of rockets problem with that
black or is actually that of all the
other Titans is that you're just again a
sitting duck everyone can see you you're
kind of slow everyone everyone is
shooting at you because they're also
have you know their own incentive to
kill you and then I engaged that fly
core which we're in which you the perk
where you move faster
then I start realizing like oh my god
this is now my favorite thing because
now I can I can fly over people I wasn't
getting as MIT as many kills with
Northstar with that ultimate now I'm
flying over people and they can't turn
around quick enough now I'm behind them
using this I do that and then I think
about other perks with Northstar for
instance twenty percent core ability
automatically yeah so now I'm exploiting
North Stars flight core ability and it's
working like it is working so well and i
just changed how i've played norstar and
that's one specific Titan but I think I
mean you say exploiting but I think one
of the cool things about tied for what
you just said is how balanced it is like
there are still ways you can take that
down and like there are some ways that I
feel like people haven't even found out
yet that that could be super vulnerable
to right yeah yeah it whenever I die in
that game compared to like other games
and shooters of the years where I've
dropped off it's this game doesn't have
that frustration and that cut sheep
nasai think other shooters can have what
when I when I died I couldn't have done
anything about that battlefield and I
love battlefield sniper cross a map just
progression you never know when again
battlefield you just die I feel like
every time or most times my plate Eiffel
doesn't always happened but most of the
time whenever I die I think what was the
lesson there and you learned from it act
like I'm just learning every freaking
time I play that game and it's just
that's what's keeping me going yeah one
one thing I do it I love it for the same
reason I love over watch the game itself
you just the changes how you look at and
how you play it depending on what Titan
you're using what your pilot loadout is
one recent combo that I just started
using like the other day is a you can
get you could do a perk where your Titan
instead of falling with she'll around it
will fall in like two seconds with no
shield so but then I got the pilot
ability where you can when you're
getting it your Titan instead of like
having it pick you up or jumping in and
then closing a cockpit you just warp in
so now I just get into my tight I call
my Tynan and get into it in like three
seconds total so I like deposited my
money and bounty hunt which is my
favorite mode turned around and then
immediately call my Titan right next to
it jumped in I was in and I was ready
like to defend the bounded like the bank
where's your mother your money yeah
gorgeous my favorite but now that I'd
like regen score yesterday i'm getting
much more into Ronin who was only like
level six before
in the knew who we were just like you
were freaking out this morning about the
day up they released the update notes
coming out to be out on wednesday week
from tomorrow so november 30th if you're
watching this after it's live Ronan now
if he gets doomed so once your health
goes down as a Titan you your your
health will just be this yellow and red
flashing bar and you're pretty much done
you can eject any time at that point but
also if someone melees you it's an
instant like assassination once Ronan's
doomed it'll automatically phase warp
him out of the fight which seems awesome
because like he's tailored toward like
close quarters and i love i love just
bomb Russian people and where they have
no idea what to do is smoke through my
sword that's why I likes courts though
excitingly counter him easily and that's
super cool like I didn't I mean
obviously they were gonna have some DLCs
I would have imagined the them respond
to have done uh maybe like a new Titan
first yeah but that makes me really
excited because yeah it's just wow
they're gonna tap into Titan kits that
almost makes more sense that makes that
will bring me back for sure try out the
new ability for this Titan like I just
think that's so cool yeah and then I
know that one of the things that got me
all riled up was like executions which
is you know like your assassination for
like a halo game there's something they
add a new one where you basically phase
warp inside someone's body and reappear
so they explode around you like Nate
says on paper yeah matrix neo the mr.
Smith I gotta see that yeah it's
exciting that game I don't want to
linger I do want to link on time fall
much longer but we don't have a ton of
time yeah I think it's all three of our
favorite shooters this year despite the
fact that there are ton of sugar don't
get into them now i will say really
quickly if you haven't played titanfall
tues campaign which i think both you
have it's like it's only like four and a
half five hours long but it's really
good between the platforming the pilot
combat the fact that you can swap Titan
loadouts on the fly to adapt to the
situation really well design there's a
mission in there that's like one of my
favorite both of our favorite like
missions in any shooter ever and it's
called effect in cause it's all I'll say
about it because you should experience
for yourselves about a little more than
halfway through the game i'd say the
campaign campaigns really well-designed
stories not the greatest but it's it's
worth playing i do want to i just
mention overwatch like that as well like
might as well be tied that's one my
favorite games of the year I blizzard
once again just goes into a new genre
nails it it's so despite the fact that
there's 20
seven characters now there's only five
to begin with I believe now with Anna
and somber introduced in the updates I
don't know like this this you have to be
a lot more patient in this game than
titanfall but we did talk about it how
especially like the 3v3 mode now i'm
getting back into and remembering why i
love that game to begin with I came out
March or may may may sorry March was a
like a few other games um I don't know
they should yeah you and I both played
over watch a lot this weekend Jake yeah
i mean i'd say overwatch is definitely
up there uh I think I I don't think I
love it as much as everyone else does
but like when you have a team of six or
even like a team of 3v3 like I don't
talk about it too much but that game is
a lot of fun like men get going in the
character diversity and all the I don't
know there's just so there's so much to
it like like the Titans in titanfall
each character has so many levels to it
like there's so much you have to figure
out but at the same time which is it has
been set a lot too but you just pick it
up and play like it's not yeah yeah no
it's it's it's easy to like figure out
what one character is about but it's not
easy to master them you see people like
I'm like Eric hey when he plays me I'm
like oh sure that's how I may is
supposed to be played and I'm nowhere
near that because they're I have like I
mean I reviewed the game I played a lot
of it and I still have been getting back
into it lately but i still only have
like six characters and I'm completely
confident with out of like 27 there's 21
other characters who like I know how to
play and I like playing them most of
them I don't think there's any character
i dislike playing there are definitely
characters i like get way more excited
about to play if i have to play them
especially if you're doing random heroes
i go i'm just saddled with like torbjorn
but then you start playing him like okay
he's actually really fun and to it
especially because people tend to hate
him but it again it like i just
mentioned this one we're talk about
titanfall 2 but i love this game because
it changes based on who you're playing
and who you're playing against and the
fact that Blizzard tried to do so much
and also nail it and still found balance
and like precision that's like crazy
especially with this many characters and
this many maps and whatnot they're not a
ton of maps but I don't know they just
found like this really good balance in
this and you know I could go on all day
about like how junk crab stacks up
against Aria and how zaria who's my
favorite character goes up against Hanzo
and everything but again like just from
the weapons everybody uses to the
abilities they use to their alts how
they affect the game
like I had you learned what's when
certain carriages are good throughout a
match I don't know Rob did you play you
played like around launch right remember
you solutely yeah I think it's a freakin
great game obviously and everyone here
in our offices like speaks like just
such appraisal for that game I think one
of the reasons is is it's got that wire
demographic of like hey I don't have to
be a twit shooter necessarily to play
this game right like I can be that
support class I can be this person and
still really kill it in that respect and
I think that's you know in person to tie
and Paul that's where I feel like maybe
not many people have been in our office
I've been like into it because there's
everyone can find their own way of
playing more so than like you know and
you know get it because its high so
heavily to like like mobile elements and
sheer ailments and it just brings so
much the table each character is like
graduated from wrong he's kind of like
not like poking fun but almost like a
poll on like different genres in a field
definitely and that's where you can
relate to X hero I mean like talking
about titanfall that diva is kind of
like it you clearly inspired by
titanfall someone that can get out of
there mech and everything you have you
know characters like Widowmaker McCree
who are probably more tire up tailored
to people who played a lot of counter
strike or anything will you have any
fixes call of duty ish yeah you he's
like the introduction you have Farrah
who's kind of a quake quake ish
character a high mobility and just like
rockets and whatnot and yeah just I
don't know it it definitely it's really
impressive how there are so many
different ways to play the game but it
is really balanced I mean they've like
they've updated characters like diva
just gotta buff recently to like up her
health and everything and then a 3v3
mode came out somber and on i like both
of those characters somber a little more
so again one of the better games of the
year in my opinion it's in my top five
definitely keep hear about this 3v3 mode
is that just because it's like more
toned down like better way of
understanding these characters because i
think that's where i'm at is like
intimidating probably like it's it's
elimination so you only have one life
unless mercy revives you but it's 3v3
it's a bus first two three round wins so
the match is like best of three best of
five sorry and you yeah you go in with
three characters yeah you start to
understand the character a little more
because you're trying to survive more
than just kill people and like push a
point or push the payload and everything
it's much more i think it's much more
focused but there are some characters
that won't be as good in it as they
would in like regular 66 yeah i mean if
you're like us it got us back in the
game like recently um but yeah
definitely check that out um yeah then
getting a big one what's that
battlefield 10 no I'm not done yet we
got a couple more we're going long today
yeah go to battlefield and then we're
gonna get into one that like yeah
battlefield one which is weird because I
think if it wasn't for titanfall in the
fact that I was actually pretty psyched
the more I learn about called duties
campaign battlefield one between the
campaign stories and just the overall
like crazy scope of the multiplayer
matches and how I usually don't like
just call out of games like visuals is
something like that I love about it like
I mean some games are good like a
battlefield wants really good looking
game between like the dew drops on
especially on PC obviously like the dew
drops on your weapons like when you
crouch in the mud you come back up it
feels very rude in this setting and it a
lot people are saying it feels more like
a world war two game but I don't know
it's great you know you're looking at
the forest maps here it's between the
war stories which is like the campaign
the actual story they're telling the
characters in them and how like varied
they were and then also just you know
getting more into I've been playing
multiplayer maps matches in between
other things and I don't know like this
game it again you have to be a little
more patient this game been tight and
fall or anything or even overwatch but
it's I know you could do so much more
than just shoot at people in this game
you can you know like just hold a point
at whether you see don't see someone for
like 15 minutes it's up to you whether
like how you want to play it but I don't
know yeah i mean this game seems like
the battlefield game that i've been
waiting for for a while like i had a lot
of fun with three i had a lot of fun
with four but the problem was that there
wasn't as much the maps one is dynamic
like you couldn't just knock out a
building necessarily and now this one
feels feels like I've way more choice in
what I'm doing and then to add to that
like the game looks stunning it's it's a
spectacle like any match you load into
you just have this huge sort of
playground in front of you and there's
60 some people like running around like
it's it's pretty impressive yeah i mean
like an one layer you have these
three different facets rate of air land
and sea in some cases see and then but
then you also had like on by ground
combat than you have tanks but it's also
real impressive of how they coalesce and
kind of make for this bigger battlefield
so you're not just worried about running
into a soldier around the next corner
you're worried like whether it tanks
there whether you should pull out your
anti-tank rocket I don't know Rob you I
mean I think everybody's familiar with
this now but you love being a pilot yeah
and that's fun because you know you that
game is yeah Jake said it like it's just
spectacle and an immersive like that's
where I feel like I I would come back to
his just for that experience right like
I you see I definitely love the air
combat but I think what's probably the
best is to like play heavily in one area
of the battlefield map and then try out
the land because what is always
surprising to me is like yeah you're in
a plane and you're just like wrecking
people with like you know an anti-tank
gun or some like that then you get on
the ground and then you look up and see
what whoever is doing the exact same
thing you were doing and it's terrifying
oh yeah we're just scared you're like
wow that was me earlier I just crapping
himself in a foxhole and I'm lucky I'll
miss that Jack I go round do again I
still there like crying like there's a
lot of those moments or it's just
intense yeah like dropping bombs out of
planes like what you're saying like huh
you drive upon that pain you don't think
about you just fly away but then like
cut to the guy on the ground and like a
building just collapsed yeah and he's a
good thing I wasn't in there yeah you
fly and it's like oh I only got like
ninety percent of his health I god what
a boss and he's very shaky I seeing red
and like Manos Ghana these great little
moments in this game that you don't even
think about until they happen I mean
like just small despite how big it isn't
how much of these maps are and how big
the battles are there are small details
that you don't really realize how
important their until they're like
happening so when you're in like a
bunker for instance those good timing
when you're a bunker it'll just be you
know you see the lights on the ceiling
shaking when like artillery's pummeling
the hill above you and that sense of
place that you get out of that
especially when you're I'll just hunker
down dust is falling from the ceiling as
a [ __ ] Zeppelin crashes on this
building nearby you it the way these
battles unfold like them not to you know
to say nothing about the dynamic weather
which is another way that can change
things up between the sandstorms or the
the fog that rolls in
so yeah I prefer to be a scout and when
fog rolls in like [ __ ] now I'm just so
terrified of assault like someone
playing a salt just rushing at me out of
the fog and I can't do much just I from
pull out my sidearm like right here it's
I don't know I really love how these
maps are huge and like it's not even
like it's forcing you to play something
different every time you could just play
it as a foot soldier every time if you
want but there's so many different ways
to play this game and again that's why I
like that's what this year has been
awesome for shooters to say the least
and battlefield one is kind of like a
microcosm of why I love that like again
just say very little about these uh the
war stories unless poil much but they
are worth playing definitely the being
the campaign and whatnot yeah I think
one of at least one of my biggest
takeaways from battlefield one though
has been like if if you're not if one
front I guess isn't going so well like
if you try and take a and it's not going
so well then you go to see and then it
almost feels like a completely different
battles going on over here and then you
go to d and like all the maps are so
well designed at least for the most of
our there's a couple that I could do
without but I don't know what it's
called but there's one where there's a
bunker on a hill and if you take this
position you have control of this anti
air gun and me and my friend was like a
squad of three of us or so and it was
just us trying to take this bunker but
there was like 12 people in there and it
was just so much fun like trying to plan
this attack with other people like it's
something that you don't really see and
I guess a multiplayer game like it was a
very slow like it's like all right so
I'm gonna go down this side I'm gonna
try to take out this guy who is I don't
know what he's doing over here huh and
then we try to go into the bunker and
then someone throws a grenade and that
messes up we try again like just the
different ways you can play kinda like
what you're just saying it's just an
example of it but it's it's it's it's
really engaging yeah bellfield 1 is 1
i'm gonna keep returning to maybe not as
often as some others but it's definitely
one of the more impressive games of the
year um I do want it like quickly before
I get those last one I want to talk a
little bit more about um what about call
duty was I think the campaign is
actually worth playing to see how they
did that how they structured it between
the seamless storytelling going between
your ship and the like starships and
then the planets are going to that
campaign the multiplayer didn't impress
me much didn't even make any changes
since black ops 3 or money changes I do
thinks campaigns worth trying out worth
playing it's pretty impressive in a lot
of ways um here's were four I thought
the game was good I liked it it was you
know like it still is like if you
was really good for third person shooter
the story was my favorite but the
hormone is great film played that and
then I mean battleborn if you're looking
for a hero shooter that came out before
overwatch couple months and I think it
kind of got lost in the shuffle because
overwatch was already in you could
already be playing it like early access
which I think that was probably on
purpose because that was their main
competitor but battleborn I don't think
did it as good a job as like finding
focus despite the fact that they were
going trying a lot of things but around
that time of year also this last one I
talked about quickly not quickly but its
doom which I think surprised all of us
maybe because it was a reboot or like I
how are they really going to do well
with us how are they gonna nail it but
one of my favorite games this year now
in a year like choc full of awesome
shooters this game even my compared to
titanfall I think this game is like
unmatched and how good it feels from
moment to moment and the campaign is
probably my favorite like single player
thing I've done this year aside from
like uncharted or something um just of
watching gameplay right now and I
already want to play it again I I had
dreams about this game when I was
playing it and and I'm that I'm not
being hyperbolic I don't usually say
[ __ ] like that but I really did I I
would wake up as horrifying and be
thinking well I had nightmares about
this game but no I would be like the
loop between our I need ammo so I'm
gonna um I'm gonna kill this guy with a
chainsaw because the killing someone
chainsaw always drops ammo but then when
I get enough ammo I'm gonna need to find
chainsaw fuel littered around the map
holy [ __ ] my health slow that dudes
glowing I can do an assassination that
will always give me health hold on let
me pull his arm off and beat him in the
face with it and he's gonna cross the
match you're just like pushing away
everyone come out you know any knees are
doing like personal goals with that game
exactly yeah it's it's you're seeing
someone across a crowded room and then
you're locking eyes oh my god they're
just trying desperately to get out but
then you punch their heads off to the
weapons feel awesome like the
double-barrel shotgun and I love when
you get into crazy firefights just this
heavy metals start pumping through your
speakers containing me after it took me
so long to finish the campaign in this
game because I play a mission my brain
would just be like oh my eyes would be
bleeding like I can't a guy gotta stop
like this is like cool yeah and I think
I don't know think we all could say that
like I yeah I think I played that game
uh like probably three hours on like
just like pure non-stop carnage
hynix when you hear you say that it's
not like a bad thing it's like a cool it
doesn't waste any time at all it's cool
shaking like just yeah all the the power
cords for every leg elimination like
where they were the glory kills glory
kills ya thank you just those uh just
those were we I think I was getting some
Nightmare flashbacks not nightmares just
like you know just that that visual
think it's cool it doesn't waste any
time getting you into it it's like
you're the do marine here's a
tablet-like guess why they buried you
here's a gun get into it you kill a few
guys ready when it opens up it's like
your next gun is like a few minutes
later and you're so I'm like this
feeling kiss it's the self-aware to
write like it's that intro where he's
Geno after what the main characters or
one of the main that AI robot who's kind
of guiding you through yes I know you
don't we kind of messed things up here
oh yeah you just got good bro like LCD
into a great lunch you know don't oh
don't punch those yeah I'm ready to turn
it off you just like sucks it and then
it's like you spot you know you spoke of
the chainsaw I remember just for the
first time in like many of games you
know like RPGs or anything like the
exploration base where it's like here's
like a page of like script yeah
sometimes you get burn out on that and I
just want continue to play the game this
was probably one of the only games where
I was super excited to read every bit of
story in the weapon like when they start
talking about the chainsaw we get it
it's the funniest thing they're just
like yeah we don't we don't really
understand why there's a chainsaw on a
space station if someone kind of just
brought it up like Japan that's
contraband so it's just kind of here on
Mars well but you have you have
everything you like the collectibles and
like exploring these maps which are
pretty open I mean their linear open I
think they called it on charge for
whatever naughty dog was talking about
you know like you can explore these like
sandbox and there's another one down the
hallway um they you want to find these
collectibles you upgrading your suit
you're upgrading your just regular
abilities you're upgrading each weapon
and each weapon when you get to like the
master tier it's just insane like the
double barrel shotgun like the reload is
nothing and you can shoot like they're
shown right here it becomes nuts and
you're fighting these this game gets
tough if you're not like using weapons
I'm good on one of the heart of
difficulties too and like it I had
trouble on that final boss and it says
something that I had a rocket launcher
in my main inventory the whole time and
I forgot sometimes like that's how crazy
some of the weapons are that like a
rocket launcher took a back seat to a
lot of what I was with a fully upgrade
machine gun that shoots missiles instead
yeah sick oh why that's why that's why
it such a freaking great campaign is is
you know with the things like runes too
yeah and me and the division of like
where a weapon can go with it's like
alternate mode is where you want to play
it again like it was it it was kind of a
tough call you had to choose between
like ah can't remember them now so long
ago like yeah the infinite mini micro
missiles or like another one for like a
machine gun it was like she's a tough
yeah you got to do it and the runes are
great because you know by the end of it
and this is where I think like titanfall
to you know minor gripe but was like oh
how cool would it be to replay titanfall
tues campaign with every load out right
beginning opposed to only getting the
last few stretches with Legion the mini
gun wielding Titan like this is where
doom like for sure was like oh I can't
wait to play it again with all those
moons and all those perks and then
played on a higher difficulty like it's
that's a really reward reward factor
that's like so worthwhile to like tackle
yeah absolutely yeah doom is up there
among like the Great's of this year the
scheme this year was like seriously just
like packed with Unreal shooters and
like we just talked about for for quite
a while and like we didn't even touch on
some of them still great shooters like I
thought yeah thank you like I thought
years war for was a good game I thought
called duties campaign was impressive I
like both some things about battle born
I don't think it all came together as
much as hot super hot was also really
good game I want to talk more about that
at some point but yeah so again that's
not like anything thing about our game
of the year yet we'll have those
discussions as a gamespot group but
those are our favorites again titanfall
2 is probably mine in terms of if I have
to give a definitive answer titanfall to
use my favorite shooter the year I think
you guys would agree yeah I think so Rob
Rob probably not I I won yet of 2016 i'm
thinking like like almost of all times
sometimes
I thought yeah I'm not even though
that's like it's a great game to play
reminds me of like playing halo combat
evolved in my garage till like by myself
and Blood Gulch cuz I'm have any friends
who were over that the time and I would
just practice good correction just doing
nothing in the game like what am i doing
I'm doing this game it's just like I
just keep every time I turn on a PSP is
for I just think about playing time yeah
side will do great game in general so
let us know what you think what your
favorite shooters are of the year and
leave your thoughts in the comments
below
[Music]